what's motivating and connecting
employees in more than 10 countries to
get up and get moving
it's a gamified fitness solution that
helps participants achieve their goals
and have fun while doing it a lot of us
spend our days sitting in fact more than
80 percent of American workers sit all
day at their jobs and many complain that
they don't get as much physical activity
as they would like research shows that
when you sit for a significant portion
of the day you face a higher risk of
musculoskeletal disorders obesity type 2
diabetes and heart disease so while it's
important to interrupt periods of
sitting with activity most of us need
motivation to get up and move around
that's what inspired a group of
Technology fanatics at IBM to create a
fitness app the app allows participants
to track and compare their percentage of
weight lost and number of steps taken
and the daily data visualization of the
top participants keeps everyone
motivated and inspired the app even
makes location-based recommendations for
nearby gyms or places to run the app has
been so successful that participants
have tracked more than 15 million steps
in less than three months
that's enough steps to walk across the
United States three times how's that for
getting active this entire fitness
solution was built in just five days
using IBM Watson data platform which
helps you build smarter applications and
quickly visualize share and gain
insights from data want some extra
energy at your workplace check out how
easy it is to set up your own fitness
solution with IBM Watson data platform